ich kann das nicht lesen
wir schreiten so eine scheiße wartberg
asse er sagt es zu viel haben wenn man
nachher weil wir erst so richtig das
bild hey leute und herzlich willkommen
zu einer neuen serie bzw zu einem neuen
konzept beziehen weil sie irgendwie
scheiße jetzt sogar mit dem hier auch
bei mir hätte willkommen wir spielen
nämlich heute sogar spiel denn wir
spielen heute ein konzept was wir wer
ist es genannt haben und zwar wo wir was
machen
wie genau und wir beide haben fünf leute
ich hab das ja so zettl haberstumpf
leute rausgesucht die wir uns dann
gegenseitig wie audi audiovisuellen das
heißt wir werden uns versuchen die
firmen der leute nach zu haben die
analysten erwarten und wer jetzt
schreibt das ist nämlich überhaupt nicht
tabu mambo denn ich habe soeben mit
meinem als abgeklärt die haben wir dafür
gegeben und zu mal machen wir das ganze
leid und wir haben da immer ein paar
fragen an euch aber das machen wir
während der aufnahmen gleich ja wir
sagen euch noch ein paar fragen am ende
bz wenn das jetzt schon hört wir
erklären euch das mal eben ganz kurz und
zwar jeder fünf leute die er sich
aussuchen kann ein bisschen haben wir
beide gerade gemacht und damals nur
sprüche aufgeschrieben oder wir müssen
halt auch die stimme verstellen so dass
wir dem anderen das so schwer wie
möglich aber erreichbar
überbringen können welcher promi und
welche promis da geht als hintergrund
habe er sie ein bisschen haldensleben
moment los geht wir werden das dann
abwechselnd halt vortragen
genau da müssen wir euch weitere fragen
die wir so machen sollen mit dem mit den
mit den punkten
und zwar wie wir wieder punkten machen
soll das heißt derjenige der welt erhält
ein punkt oder derjenige der es nicht
erreicht
da müssen wir das wäre ganz gut wenn es
dann mal die kommentare schreibt müssen
die punkte machen sollen ok ja genau und
auch wichtig ist dass wir uns später
prominente und heute in die kommentare
schreiben
am ende vom ok wenn man von mir aus
kannst du anfangen dann kann ich mir das
ein bisschen anhören so wie du das so
macht sich direkt mit in einem anfang
was du erreichen kannst du damit richtig
mir egal
da steht ein häuschen war das einstellen
hey wie mach ich denke ich habe hier
fünf leute stehen also ok luca das ist
der erste los geht's meine damen und
herren hier zur 7 schon abends im
fernsehen zu sehen ja was war denn da
los
ich weiß was ich will ich weiter schlag
den raab bei schlag den raab
multitalente macht eine ganze show auf
einmal ja stefan raab
ihr dürft übrigens immer mit raten wenn
ihr die stimme hört könnt ihr schon die
kommentare schreiben und vielleicht seid
schneller ihr könnt auch tricksen aber
das wird das spart wegnehmen also ihr
könnt ruhig auch wenn man gibt so nach
und nach ein bisschen tricksen
er hat auch mal meine spieler danach
geht der wird
für mich kam das nicht lesen ey wir
schreiten zum start der käfer bei frauen
ohne witz ich habe mir den ausschnitt
geguckt und war deshalb video heißt
einfach erdberg käse kette rossmann ich
komme vor nicht drauf ist bei den ersten
wörtern wie es lena oder rotwild fackel
gebrannt wird über proxy wettgemacht bin
ich ein alter witz ich weiß worum es
geht ja okay wir verraten dass nicht das
müsst ihr jetzt in die fremde das sein
könnte das ist also der hatte maas
anspruch den erhalt bringt aber ich sag
jetzt hat den spruch ohne den namen muss
gerade noch töten wenn wir traurig dass
das essen genießen und zwar
kann mein name ist ein comeback nach
einfach einfach das den namen einfach
aus haben amys aber comeback aber wer
dir mama channel
du musst es beim und dabei sehen
aber du kannst es nicht sehen aber so
auf jeden fall ein youtube es ist ein
youtube
weißt du nie richtig tipps geben tipps
aktive martins bruder war damals in
australien gewohnt wohnt jetzt in
england london
vor allem weil ich doch nicht kennst du
dich nicht mehr ist so von kennst du
sechs cap dann erkennt den 600.000 oder
sollte man kennen
deshalb sollen vielleicht machen wir
nächsten runde
doch wir lassen uns jetzt mal richtig
hart
wir können uns kraft dahinter lag da 18
das ist alles ziemlich spontan hier
aufgenommen
sie möchte nicht kannten das einfach nur
faul dieses stück scheiße wird ein
hochgepuscht [ __ ] hochtouren sollen
ja klar
doch nur noch 273 sekunden revier aber
nein wir müssen ja ich bin rausgekickt
doch es geht los
ich habe nämlich kein premium mehr weil
das irgendwie weg ist wenn ihr ganz ganz
geile zeit kaufte mir das aber ich will
euch das nicht unterstellen dass musste
noch dazu das ist kennst du kannst auf
jeden fall ganz kurz gucken wo ich mich
versteckt platz ich habe richtig haben
richtig geschlossen die relativ guten
platz jetzt das so schlecht nach gemacht
das ist so schlecht nachgewürzt und
natürlich sagen das ist natürlich nicht
so wie das jetzt aussieht
christoph maria herbst stromberg wo bald
auch einen film im kino läuft wo die
aussehen bei mir zuhause szenen bei mir
fast zuhause gedreht haben in der nähe
folge hätte also stromwechsel hammergeil
serie muss ich sagte ich alle
stromberger wenn ihr das nicht kennt wie
steht's eigentlich von punkt a ja wir
machen das bisher nur so damit ihr das
kennenlernen
schreibt uns eure kommentare wie wir das
mit dem punkt machen wollen wir standen
kommentare bewerten sammelpunkten und
ihr könnt uns auch leute in die
kommentare schreiben
die wir so phantom
die rennen sollen das ist ein zitat in
amsterdam
die aus zumindest meinen
ja gesagt wenn du bist du [ __ ]
gegenwart es kommt zu viel besser ja
aber dann hätten vielleicht doch eher
erraten vukan stand schnauze okay ich
bin dran
luca luka den erreger auf anhieb okay
okay
erst richtig grenzwertig den bringen ja
mag richtig sein wird springen sogar
schon vorher wirklich bringt
ganz professionell wie sag mal wo du
bist dann komme ich eben zu dir hin
warum nein da können wir zusammen
verstecken bis schon gemüse
okay wer nächster aber viel du für mich
runter dann fange ich an
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge minecraft mussten raus
finden
das ist ein ernst das heißt wer ist
einfach selber ich dachte da kommst du
nicht drauf ich wollte zum tricky mickey
sein muss einfach auf jeden fall heraus
horst schlämmer mir bewusst gemacht
ja ok es kommt der nächste familie rede
ich brauche ein countdown ein macht mir
keinen karton alter fröhlich nicht gut
mit konnte ich ja gar nicht war gar
nicht irgendwie aber nie gesagt hat das
richtig ist aber nur gesagt scheiße okay
ich bin noch dabei wild auf alles drauf
zu schlagen jetzt kommt schon dieses
komische geräusche okay was die
anschuldigung betrifft so denke ich
verdiene ich von diesem gremium ein
bisschen debatte jedenfalls was die
anschuldigungen betrifft denke ich
verdiene ich ein wenig anerkennung von
diesem gremium 29 keine ahnung ich weiß
es nicht
du weißt dass es ist in dem film ja das
weiß ich es wird gespielt mark
zuckerberg
die schauspieler zu wissen klar
keine ahnung ich werde wieder heißt nein
junge den schauspieler soll ist der rat
nicht die figur ja aber auf jeden fall
nicht magst du wenn du mir den namen
gedacht hätte ich ihm bewusst wie viel
sport fit dass sie darüber diesen locken
lässt fortgehen bei gott nein
die nord gegen das ist okay das haus von
dieser ersten etwas improvisierten folge
von wer ist es und wenn das nächste
folge noch reißt euch euren daumen ab
und drücken auf das video wenn ihr mehr
davon wollte ohne witz und wenn ihr das
ganze mit facetime sehen wollt ich weiß
was du gemacht ich gehe ja klar ich
nämlich nicht wenn ich hab eben ein
richtiges prügel gesicht und wieso der
star aus der nase oder stephen hawking
halt geben und so jetzt müssen wir auch
wer das war luca wen hast du mir geraten
ach ja stimmt
hast du ihn ich nachher empoli sich das
bild
wenn du bei mir nicht erraten hat ist
das habe ich sogar schon mit der folge
gesagt das war kasperle der iaa deswegen
ich kannte diese in berlin gebrannt aber
ich kann diesen namen nicht da war mir
nicht mehr so bekannt doch was nicht
erkannt außerdem den letzten spieler wie
heißt er denn weiß ich nicht und jeder
jeder der schreibt bekommt man regel mir
einen daumen hoch bei den kommentaren ok
meine freunde das was man erst folgen
wir freuen uns auf jeden fall sollte uns
auch leute in die kommentare schreiben
unterhalten uns in die kommentare ja
erstens nicht leute wir nachahmen sollen
aber nicht weil wir die gleichen wie bei
mir gleich bescheid verhängt du bist
meine freunde so naiv wie es läuft und
er schreibt uns ein punktesystem in den
kommentaren soll der im punkt kriegen
der das gerät oder ganz anders oder der
nicht rauskriegt auf jeden fall